THIS COMMITTEE ON AGING AND LONG
TERM CARE IT IS NOW IN SESSION
WE'RE GONNA START AS A SUB
COMMITTEE BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE
A FULL QUORUM -- FIRST STEP IS A
AB FOR EIGHTY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SALIS [inaudible]
WELCOME.
VETERANS HER NUMBERS
[inaudible]
AFTER WE IT ONLY STARTED AS OF
TWO AND A HALF MONTHS AGO BUT
THANK YOU FOR THAT RECOGNITION
UBER ADULTS SINCE.
TWO THOUSAND SEVEN HOWEVER THIS
POSITION NO LONGER EXISTS AFTER
STATE BUDGET CUTS AND TWENTY
ELEVEN ELIMINATED FUNDING FOR
THE GERIATRIC MENTAL HEALTH
SPECIALIST ONE AND FIVE OLDER
ADULTS.
EXPERIENCES MENTAL HEALTH
CONCERNS HOWEVER LESS THAN ONE
THIRD OF OLDER ADULTS THE UNITED
STATES -- I ACTUALLY HAVE MENTAL
HEALTH CARE'S THAT ARE ACTUALLY
MEANT.
THE STUDY WAS CONDUCTED BY THE
UCLA CENTER FOR HEALTH POLICY
RESEARCH WAS SUPPORT WHAT FROM
THE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
OVERSIGHT AND ACCOUNTABILITY
COMMISSION.
FOUND A NUMBER OF CHALLENGES AND
DEFICIENCIES IN THE CURRENT
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH STRUCTURE FOR
OLDER ADULTS.
THAT THIS BILL SEEKS TO ADDRESS
BY ESTABLISHING STATEWIDE LEADER --
WITH ME I DO HAVE TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT AND WOULD APPRECIATE AN
AYE VOTE WHEN IT'S APPROPRIATE.
THANK YOU ARE THEIR WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK.
YOU KNOW WHAT BEFORE WE START
SINCE WE HAVE A QUORUM IN PLACE
WHY DON'T WE DOOR QUICK ROLL
CALL.
AND AND THEN WE CAN CONTINUE. TO
TAKE YOUR TIME AND GET READY --
A SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
THIS AREA [inaudible]
PRESENT [inaudible]
VOEPEL [inaudible]
WARNER HORVAT [inaudible]
KALRA [inaudible]
LACKEY [inaudible]
REYES [inaudible]
RUBIO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THE START.
OKAY MIKE SON.
OKAY YES I SURELY CROWN WITH A
CALIFORNIA SENIOR LEGISLATURE
AND HE ORIGINAL AUTHOR OF THIS
PARTICULAR BILL.
AND I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME HERE 22% THE SENATE
BILL TO ALL OF YOU -- I THINK
THAT THE THE ONE ISSUE THAT I
WANT TO GET ACROSS RIGHT NOW IS
IF THERE ISN'T ANY OVERSIGHT ON
HELL MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES.
ARE PROVIDED TO OLDER ADULTS.
THIS IS WHY ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR
EIGHTY IS AN ESSENTIAL BILL
MOVING FORWARD.
THERE WAS AN ADMINISTRATIVE
POSITION THAT YOU MAY BE AWARE
OF IN PLACE FROM TWO THOUSAND
SEVEN UNTIL. TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN
TO BRIDGE THE DEPARTMENT OF
MENTAL HEALTH AND THE DEPARTMENT
OF AGING.
MUCH WAS ACCOMPLISHED AND THE
AGING SERVICES NETWORK WAS
MOBILIZED IN COUNTIES ACROSS THE
STATE.
OFFERING EVIDENCE BASED.
DEPRESSION MANAGEMENT AS WELL AS
EARLY INTERVENTION PROGRAMS.
IT IS SAID THAT DUE TO BUDGET
SHORTFALLS IMPACTING MANY
PROGRAMS.
THE GOVERNOR RE DIRECTED THIS
FUNDING TO COUNTIES FOR MENTAL
HEALTH PREVENTION SERVICES AND
THIS IS WHERE WE RAN INTO SOME
ISSUES.
OVERSIGHT ACCOUNTABILITY FOR BID
TO HOST THE HEALTH SERVICES
FUNDS AND PROGRAMS IS AN
IMPERATIVE FOR BOTH THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES.
AND THE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
OVERSIGHT AND ACCOUNTABILITY
COMMISSION.
THE STATE LEVEL POSITION WOULD
BE RESPONSIBLE FOR ENSURING THE
MENTAL HEALTH PLANS SUBMITTED
ARE REVIEWED TO ENSURE THAT THE
FUNDING REQUESTED WAS ACTUALLY
USED TO FUND THE PLAN SUBMITTED.
THIS IS VITALLY IMPORTANT.
IF A PLAN IMPLEMENTED CREATES AN
INNOVATIVE PROGRAM SOLVED IT
SHOULD BE SOMETHING TO BE SHARED
WITH OTHER COUNTY ORGANIZATIONS
FOR THEIR CONSIDERATION.
IT IS ALSO IMPORTANT TO
RECOGNIZE THAT HALF THE COUNTIES
IN CALIFORNIA REPORT THAT THEY
HAVE AN ADMINISTRATIVE UNIT FOR
THE SERVICES.
THAT TO DO THAT.
THOSE THAT DO HAVE A ROBUST
PROGRAM.
OTHERS HOWEVER TEND TO BELIEVE
THAT OLDER ADULTS ARE.
ADULTS WHO WERE JUST OLD.
AND THEY DO NOT RECOGNIZE THE
COMPLEX MEDICAL ISSUES THAT ALSO
NEED TO BE TAKEN INTO
CONSIDERATION IN MENTAL HEALTH
PLANNING PROGRAMS AND SERVICE
DELIVERY.
MANY CAN'T COUNTIES DO NOT
PURPOSELY REACH OUT TO OLDER
ADULTS TO OFFER NECESSARY
SPECIAL MENTAL HEALTH PROGRAMS.
I CAN ALSO TELL YOU THAT FROM MY
OWN PERSONAL RESEARCH THERE ARE
ORGANIZATIONS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THAT WILL SUBMIT A
PLAN. FOR THEIRMENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES IN THEIR PARTICULAR
COUNTY.
AND THEY END UP USING THAT MONEY
FOR SOMETHING ELSE THERE'S NO
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR HOW THAT
MONEY IS BEING SPENT WHICH IS
THIS WHAT THIS BILL WOULD DO.
IN THE PAST THE DEPARTMENT OF
MENTAL HEALTH HAD PULLED TEAMS
WORKING ON CHILDREN'S ISSUES NO
SPECIALIST FOR OLDER ADULTS.
WELL CHILDREN'S ISSUES CONTINUE
TO BE IMPORTANT.
OLDER ADULTS NEED TO BE TREATED
EQUALLY WE ALL KNOW THE AGING
POPULATION IS RAPIDLY EXPANDING
AND IF YOU DON'T KNOW THAT.
I CAN'T HELP YOU.
THANK YOU SHIRLEY.
AND GOOD AFTERNOON -- CHAIR
NAZARIAN VICE CHAIR VOCAL AND
DISTINGUISHED MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
MY NAME IS KATHERINE KATE SPENT
ON A RESEARCH SCIENTIST AT THE
UCLA CENTER FOR HEALTH POLICY
RESEARCH I AM PLEASED TO BE HERE
TODAY TO PRESENT.
SOME OF THE FINDINGS FROM A
STUDY WE COMPLETED IN LATE
TWENTY SEVENTEEN THAT ARE QUITE
RELEVANT TO THE BILL THAT IS
UNDER CONSIDERATION HERE TODAY
AB.
FOR EIGHTY IN TWENTY FIFTEEN WE
WERE CONTRACTED BY THE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION TO
EVALUATE HOW OLDER ADULTS WERE
BEING SERVED BY THE PUBLIC
MENTAL HEALTH DELIVERY SYSTEM.
AND WHAT PROGRESS HAS BEEN MADE
SINCE PASSAGE OF THE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES ACT OF TWO
THOUSAND AND FOUR TO MY
KNOWLEDGE THAT'S THE ONLY TIME
THAT OLDER ADULTS.
AND THEIR EXPERIENCE UNDER THE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ACT FUNDS
HAS BEEN INVESTIGATED.
LITTLE BIT ABOUT WHAT WE FOUND
THROUGH THE COURSE OF OUR STUDY.
WE FOUND THERE WERE SIGNIFICANT
UNMET SERVICE NEEDS AND A VERY
ON EVEN RESPONSE TO OLDER ADULTS
WITH SERIOUS MENTAL ILLNESS.
WE FOUND VERY FEW EXAMPLES OF
PROGRAMS OUR OUTREACH EFFORTS
THAT WERE SPECIFICALLY TAILORED
TO MEET THE SPECIAL NEEDS OF
OLDER ADULTS AS SURELY AS
POINTED OUT.
OFTEN WITH COMPLEX MEDICAL
CONDITIONS THAT REALLY CAN
COMPLICATE THE TREATMENT OF
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH ISSUES.
WE ALSO FOUND SERIOUS DEFICITS
IN THE GERIATRICS WORK FORCE
INCLUDING A LACK OF GERIATRIC
PSYCHIATRISTS AND FEW
OPPORTUNITIES FOR CROSS TRAINING
ACROSS AGING AND MENTAL HEALTH
SPECIALISTS.
OUTCOME MEASUREMENT AND
REPORTING DATA AT THE COUNTY
LEVEL WAS QUITE LIMITED WHILE
SOME COUNTIES INCLUDED OUTCOME
DATA FOR OLDER ADULTS MOST
LACKED INFORMATION ON THE
PENETRATION OR THE EFFECTIVENESS
OF THESE PROGRAMS.
FINALLY WHILE WE IDENTIFIED
PROMISING PROGRAMS THAT MANY
COUNTIES PUT FORTH TO ADDRESS
SOME OF THESE DEFICITS THESE
EFFORTS WERE UNEVENLY
IMPLEMENTED.
THERE WERE DISPARITIES FOUND
BOTH WITHIN A CROSS COUNTIES
WITH RESPECT TO THE ACCESS TO
CARE AND QUALITY OF CARE FOR
OLDER ADULTS WITH MENTAL HEALTH
AND BEHAVIOR HEALTH NEEDS.
SO BASED ON OUR FINDINGS WE
IDENTIFIED SEVERAL ACTIONS THAT
COULD BE TAKEN TO ADDRESS SOME
OF THESE DEFICITS AND IMPROVE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES FOR OLDER
ADULTS.
THESE RECOMMENDATIONS INCLUDE
ESTABLISHING AN ADMINISTRATIVE
LEADERSHIP POSITION AT THE STATE
LEVEL DEDICATED TO OLDER ADULT
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES.
WITH THE PROPER AUTHORITY THE
LEADERSHIP POSITION COULD
CONTRIBUTE TO AN OVERSEE THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF POLICIES THAT
BETTER SERVES THE CONCERNS OF
OLDER ADULTS WITH MEANT MENTAL
OR BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CONDITIONS.
SUCH A POSITION WOULD PROVIDE
NEEDED OVERSIGHT FOR MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES FOR OLDER ADULTS
AND COULD ALSO ESTABLISH
STANDARDIZED DATA REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS USING STANDARDIZED
ASSESSMENTS.
TOOLS THAT FOR OLDER ADULTS AND
CORPS MENTAL HEALTH DATA
OUTCOMES.
HOW CAN MEASURES?
I'M A STATE LEVEL OLDER ADULT
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
ADMINISTRATOR WOULD ALSO BE
POSITION TO GUIDE COUNTY LEVEL
EFFORTS TO ENHANCE OLDER ADULTS
OUT REACH AND DOCUMENTATION OF
UNMET NEED.
THEY WOULD ALSO PROMOTE
STANDARDIZED GERIATRIC TRAINING
A PROVIDERS AT THE COUNTY LEVEL
AN INCREASE SERVICE INTEGRATION
EFFORTS WHICH ARE SO CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT ESPECIALLY WEEK
BETWEEN MEDICAL BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH AGING AND SUBSTANCE USE
SERVICES. TO PROVE TO PROMOTE
COMPREHENSIVE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES FOR OLDER ADULTS AND
MORE INFORMATION ABOUT THE STUDY
IF YOU LIKE I HAVE A LITTLE.
HANDY FACT SHEET SHARE THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU -- ARE THERE.
ANY OTHER SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
CHEN IS ARIANNA MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE CHAIRED HAMPTON ON
BEHALF LEADING IS CALIFORNIA.
THE H. COMPANY REPRESENTS OVER
SIX HUNDRED NOT FOR PROFIT
PROVIDERS A SENIOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING CARE.
AND SERVICES TO APPROXIMATELY
ONE HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND OLDER
ADULTS HERE IN CALIFORNIA I JUST
WANT TO THAT WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
THE BILL.
RIDLEY THAT THIS WILL HELP
PROVIDE SOME THE TOOLS RESOURCES
NEEDED TO ADDRESS MENTAL HEALTH
IN OLDER ADULTS FOR COMMUNITIES
THANK YOU VERY MUCH [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND DEBBIE
TOTH WITH CHOICE AN AGING AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL --
SURELY CROWN LEADING THE CAUSES
ADVISORY COUNCIL ON AGING
IMMEDIATE PAST PRESIDENT IN
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY.
AND YOU COULDN'T HAVE A MORE
INCREDIBLE ADVOCATE FOR SENIORS
AND HAVING BEEN A PROVIDER OF
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ACT
FUNDING FOR OLDER ADULTS I CAN
TELL YOU THE ISSUES ARE HUGE AND
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MAN WARRANT A MEMBER OF
CALIFORNIA SENIOR LEGISLATURE
BUT I'M SPEAKING TO YOU TODAY.
AS A MEMBER OF THE ADVISORY
COUNCIL FOR SAN FRANCISCO COUNTY
AND WE DID SUPPORT THIS AND I
BELIEVE WROTE A LETTER TO
SUPPORT IT SO I ASK YOU TO FOR
YOUR VOTE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON ERIN LEAVE I
REPRESENT THE CALIFORNIA SYSTEM
LIVING ASSOCIATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
SECOND.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WE STILL HAVE A SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR
JOHN PORTER CALIFORNIA SENIOR
LEGISLATURE IT'S MY PLEASURE
PROVIDE MY SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
ANYBODY ELSE -- ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE ANY QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE [inaudible]
YES.
MISTER CHAIR JUST A QUICK
COMMENT -- WONDERFUL BILL THANK
YOU VERY BADLY NEEDED.
AND I WAS PUT MY TWO CENTS IN
FOR VETERANS -- WE'RE FINDING
OUT THAT THE AFGHANISTAN AND I'M
A ROCKY VETERANS ARE DEVELOPING
ALZHEIMER'S DISEASE TEN YEARS
EARLIER THAN THE VIETNAM
VETERANS SO THIS BILL WILL HELP
THEM GREATLY.
AND ALSO I ALWAYS REMIND PEOPLE
AND VETERANS THAT -- TWENTY TWO
VETERANS COMMIT SUICIDE EVERY
DAY.
AND WOMEN.
VETERANS.
PER CAPITA.
ARE COMMITTING SUICIDE 65%
HIGHER THAN MEN.
AND THE VETERANS ADMINISTRATION
HAS NOT.
RESEARCH THAT YET.
SO THIS BILL IS SPOT ON THANK
YOU VERY MUCH SIR.
WELL DONE THANK YOU THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
CLOSE CLOSING COMMENTS OKAY.
THE I'M SORRY MISTER CELIS.
NO I JUST WANT TO ALSO VOICE MY
STRONG SUPPORT FOR THIS AND
APPRECIATION THAT YOU BROUGHT
THIS FORWARD.
MENTAL BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AND MY
DISTRICT IS A REALLY REALLY
IMPORTANT ISSUE -- ESPECIALLY
AMONG OUR SENIORS AND REALLY
HAVE MAKING SURE THAT FUNDING IS
GOING TO WHERE IT NEEDS TO GO IS
AND HAVING THEM INITIATIVE
OVERSIGHT.
IS CRITICAL TO MAKING SURE THOSE
WHONEED THE SERVICES ARE
GETTING IT SO THANK YOU FOR SO
MUCH.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SOUNDS FOR BRING
THIS FOR IT AND ALL YOUR SUPPORT
AND ALL THE PEOPLE HERE WHO
SUPPORTED THE SPELL THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
THANK YOU SO MUCH CLOSING
COMMENTS -- NOT -- DON'T JUST
SAY THAT -- THEIR APPRECIATE
COMMENTS FOR THE DíAS AND PRE
SHEET THE SUPPORT -- YOU KNOW
WE'RE LOOKING AT MENTAL HEALTH
FOR SENIORS YOU KNOW ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WE DID MENTION
EARLIER.
MR VOEPEL TOUCHED UPON IT FOR
VETERANS BUT IN EVEN WHEN YOU
LOOK AT THE POPULATION.
OUT FRONT THERE WAS A STUDY FROM
NINETEEN NINETY ONE TO TWENTY
SEVENTEEN FROM THE AGE GROUPS OF
SIXTY FIVE TO EIGHTY FOUR NO 50%
OF THOSE SENIORS ACTUALLY
COMMITTED SUICIDE.
AND WHEN YOU LOOK AT SENIORS
OVER THE AGE OF EIGHTY FIVE
THAT'S 50% OF COMMITTED SUICIDE
SO WE REALLY DO THE THIS -- THE
MENTAL HEALTH WE NEED TO TAKE
CARE OF THEM PHYSICALLY BUT ALSO
MENTALLY AS WELL WITH THAT
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU AND I JUST WANT TO
CLARIFY -- YOU WILL BE TAKING
THE AMENDMENTS YES FANTASTIC
THANK YOU THE JUST GIVEN THE
GIVEN THE FRAGMENTATION THE IN
THIS AREA AND GIVEN THE ROW.
NO WRONG DOOR APPROACH IN
MASTER PLAN TO TRY TO CORDON
BETTER COORDINATE IN THESE AREAS --
I THINK IT WAS IMPORTANT FOR
DEPARTMENT OF AGING TO CONTINUE
PROVIDING THE SERVICES AS WELL
SO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND A WE'LL
BE SUPPORTING THIS BILL AS WELL --
AND LET'S THE OPEN NO ROLL CALL.
WHEN DO THE ABOUT -- I GUESS THE
HOUSEKEEPING ITEM THAT WE NEED
TO DO -- SINCE THE SINCE WE DO
HAVE A QUORUM ESTABLISH NOW WHY
DON'T WE ADOPT THE COMMITTEE
RULES -- TO SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
NAZARIAN I'VE NAZARIAN AYE
VOEPEL.
HELLO HI WARNER HARD ROCK.
I WARNER **** FIVE I KALRA.
KALRA I LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE RADIUS RUBIO
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THE BILL IS OUT THANK YOU.
AND THE NEXT BILL IS ALSO MISTER
SALAS [inaudible]
OF COURSE.
LET'S OPEN THE ROLE FOR A
THERE'S A MOTION.
KALRA AND MISTER VOEPEL I
BELIEVE SECOND IT RIGHT.
OF COURSE.
SAYS THE OPENER -- FOUR EIGHTY
FOUR EIGHTY AB PORT EIGHTY
NAZARIAN AYE NAZARIAN AYE VOEPEL.
I BORDER HARD ROCK I'VE FOR YOUR
HOME ROTH AYE KALRA.
KALRA I LACKEY I'VE LACKEY AYE
REYES.
RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE THE MEASURE PASSES
[inaudible]
MR SALAS.
YOU HAVE YOUR SECOND BILL YES.
EIGHTY NINE SEVENTY THANK YOU
MISTER COMMITTEE MEMBERS
ASSEMBLY BILL NINE SEVENTY WOULD
PROVIDE CLEAN TRANSPORTATION FOR
SENIORS AND THE DISABLED TO
HEALTH CARE APPOINTMENTS IN
RURAL AREAS.
WHERE THERE ARE MANY EXISTING
BARRIERS -- TO HEALTH CARE
ACCESS SPECIFICALLY THIS BILL
WOULD ESTABLISH A GRANT PROGRAM
ADMINISTERED BY THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT AGING WHICH PROVIDE
FOR THE PURCHASE OR LEASE OF
ZERO MISSION OR NEAR ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES. TO PROVIDE
TRANSPORTATION TO AND FROM NON
EMERGENCY MEDICAL CARE
APPOINTMENTS FOR OLDER
INDIVIDUALS PERSONS LIVING WITH
DISABILITIES WHO RESIDE IN RURAL
DESERT.
OR MOUNTAIN AREAS THIS IS LET ME
JUST.
TELL YOU MISTER IS A PROBLEM
THAT I PROBABLY HEAR ABOUT --
THE MOST AT TOWN HALLS AND JUST
DIFFERENT COMMUNITY COFFEE.
IN MY DISTRICT AND AND TALKING
ABOUT COLLEAGUES THIS IS
SOMETHING WE HEAR ABOUT I THINK
UP AND DOWN THE ENTIRE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA -- SENIOR JUST TRYING
TO GET TO THEIR MEDICAL
APPOINTMENTS AND TRY TO FIND THE
TRANSPORTATION TO DO THAT.
AND SO WITH HERS WITH THAT
MOTION AND THAT SECOND I'D
APPRECIATE LABOR THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WITH THIS IS IN SUPPORT.
I WAS WONDERING IF YOU REALLY
NEED IN MY AREA MY WITNESSING --
FOR THE RECORD.
I'VE AND WARREN FROM CALIFORNIA
SENIOR LEGISLATURE IN WHERE THE
SPONSOR AND THE AUTHOR OF THIS
BILL AND WHAT I'D LIKE TO REMIND
YOU IS THAT WE DO HAVE MANY
SENIORS WHO SUFFER FROM CHRONIC
DISEASES.
AND PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES WHO
HAVE DIFFICULTY.
GETTING TO THEIR MEDICAL
APPOINTMENTS AND I ASK YOU.
I HEARD DAM ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LACKEY.
MENTION HIS LATEST BIRTHDAY
[inaudible]
MILESTONE [inaudible] SIXTY VERY
GOOD.
BUT IMAGINE IF YOU WERE.
SEVENTY AND COULD NOT -- YES I
DO TOO I HOPE YOU GET THEIR TO
BUT IF THE BEEN DISCHARGED FROM
ACUTE HOSPITAL.
AND TOLD TO GET THAT YOU HAVE TO
COME BACK FOR TREATMENTS.
AND THAT YOU LIVE QUITE A
DISTANCE AWAY.
IN A RURAL AREA.
THAT BECOMES A CONTENDER.
DOESN'T -- ALSO YOU KNOW WE ADD
TO IT THE FACT THAT NEITHER YOU
NOR YOUR FAMILY MEMBERS HAVE
TRANSPORTATION. FOR A MYRIAD OF
REASONS.
WHAT YOU GONNA DO YOU CHOOSE FOR
LOOK TO FRIENDS YOU LOOK TO
NEIGHBORS?
BUT THEY MAY NOT BE AVAILABLE --
IN MENDOCINO COUNTY RESIDENT
TOLD US THAT THEY HAVE A
VOLUNTEER ORGANIZATION THAT
PROVIDES THIS SERVICE.
BUT THEY'RE HAVING PROBLEMS
RECRUITING THE DRIVERS BECAUSE
THE DRIVERS DON'T WANT TO PUT
THE WEAR AND TEAR ON THEIR
PERSONAL VEHICLES -- LOCAL
TRANSIT.
MANY AREAS HAVE NO SERVICE
WHATSOEVER.
DEPARTMENT ON AGING DOESN'T HAVE
CONTRACT FUNDS AVAILABLE FOR
TRANSPORTATION THE MONEY'S THAT
THEY HAVE BEEN ALLOW IT ALLOTTED
TO THEM HAS TO BE USED FOR
DIRECT SERVICES.
BECAUSE YOU HAVE SAID.
THROUGH THE LEGISLATURE.
AGING IN PLACE IS A PRIORITY.
AN EXCEPTION HOWEVER.
WE SEE AN SAN BERNADINE KNOWS
RURAL AREA.
IS A RIDER'S CENTERED.
VOLUNTEER PROGRAM.
IN WHICH THE WRITERS IN ROLAND
PROGRAM.
RECRUIT THEIR OWN VOLUNTEER
DRIVERS AND RECEIVE MILEAGE
REIMBURSEMENTS. FOR THE THE
TRANSPORTATION.
IN MANY OF CALIFORNIA SMALLER
COUNTIES THAT'S OVER HALF OF OUR
COUNTIES IN THE STATE.
ACTUAL NUMBERS OF UNSERVED
SENIORS IS UNKNOWN.
BUT WITH GOVERNMENT POLICIES
ENCOURAGING SAYS A SENIOR STATE
AGENT PLACE AND THE LACK OF
HOUSING ALTERNATIVES THEIR
CLUSTERS OF VERY SMALL
RESIDENTIAL ENCLAVES.
OFTEN WITH POOR RESIDENTS
THROUGHOUT OUR VERY RURAL AREAS.
WE FEEL THAT THESE INDIVIDUALS
NEED SERVICE ALSO.
THE TRANSPORTATION PROBLEMS AT
LAKE IN MENDOCINO COUNTIES.
OCCUR STEM FROM RURAL LOW
DENSITY POPULATION BASE.
AND SEPARATED BY MANY MILES AND
MOUNTAINS AND LAKES.
MANY SENIORS THERE NAY
TRANSPORTATION TO FAR OFF
LOCATIONS SUCH AS SANTA ROSA AND
SAN FRANCISCO FOR SPECIALIZED
MEDICAL TREATMENTS.
TRANSPORTATION BETWEEN THE TOWNS
AND CITIES WITHIN THE COUNTIES
IS DIFFICULT.
AND EXPENSIVE BECAUSE OF THE
DISTANCE. ONE OF OUR MEMBERS IN
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT.
TO SAYS IN PRACTICE THE MORE
URBANIZED AREAS ARE SERVICED.
STATEWIDE NON EMERGENCY
TRANSPORT SERVICES FOR HIGHER.
ARE PRIMARILY AVAILABLE NEAR
URBAN AND SUBURBAN AREAS SUCH AS
ORANGE AND SAN DIEGO COUNTIES.
AND IN THE NORTHEAST SERVICES
AVAILABLE TO AREAS FROM SAN JOSE
TO MORAN COUNTIES.
AND EAST TO ALAMEDA AND SENT
SENT ACROSS TO COUNTY.
MOST OF THESE PRIVATE COMPANIES
UP HERE TO USE MODIFIED
AMBULANCE VEHICLES.
THAT HOLD A SMALL NUMBER OF
PEOPLE [inaudible] ONE EXCEPTION.
ONE EXCEPTION IN THE STATE.
IS MEDI VAN.
OPERATED BY STANISLAUS COUNTY.
A TRANSIT WHICH IS INEXPENSIVE
RESERVATION ONLY SERVICE FROM
MODESTO TO OAKLAND SAN FRANCISCO
IN PALO ALTO. ONE USER OF THIS
SERVICE RELATED TO ME THAT SHE
MUST DRIVE. TO GET THE
TRANSPORTATION FROM HER HOME IN
TO WOLLEMI COUNTY TO MODESTO. TO
CATCH THE VAN TO GET TO UC SAN
FRANCISCO TO MEET WITH HER
CARDIOLOGISTS.
IF ONE IS NOT FEELING WELL.
EVEN THAT SERVICE CAN BE
DIFFICULT.
GETTING OLD IS IN LEVEL.
BEING OLD AND POOR IS A
CHALLENGE.
BEING SICK IS A GREATER
BEING OLD SICK AND LIVING IN
REMOTE ISOLATED AREAS CAN BE A
BURDEN.
BUT HAVING TRANSPORTATION FOR
ACCESSING YOUR MEDICAL NEEDS
LESSONS THE CHALLENGE.
WE'RE PROPOSING THIS MEDICAL
TRANSIT SOLUTION THROUGH THE
PURCHASE AND OPERATIONS OF
ENERGY RENEWABLE VEHICLES FROM
THE GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION
FUND.
THAT ADDRESS THE RURAL SERIOUS
I'M SORRY SENIOR AND DISABLED
COMMUNITIES NEEDS.
AND CONTINUED TO ACHIEVE THE
GOALS.
OF REDUCING EMISSIONS.
WE HOPE THAT YOU AGREE AND VOTE
FOR THIS BILL [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER SUPPORTERS.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MY NAME IS
MARK WHAT'S I'M HERE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF THE CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY.
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS -- WE'VE
RECENTLY COME TO APPRECIATE THIS
BILL AND WE ONLY GOT A LETTER IN.
THIS LAST WEEK TO THE AUTHORS
OFFICE IN SUPPORT IN FAVOR OF
THE BILL WE DID THE BOARD STOP
SHORT OF TAKING A SUPPORT
POSITION.
BUT THEY WERE WE THEY'VE ASKED
US TO WORK WITH YOUR OFFICE AS
WE MOVE FORWARD WE ARE VERY
STRONGLY IN SUPPORT OF THE IDEA
OF USING G. G. R. F.. FOR SOME
OF THESE ACTIVITIES AND WE'VE
GOT DONE SOME RESEARCH HAVE WE
FEEL SHOWS THAT THERE'S A
CORRELATION BETWEEN.
GREENHOUSE GAS AND IN DOING SOME
OF THESE -- NEW TRANSPORTATION
FUNDING OPPORTUNITIES SO
APPRECIATE.
YOUR ATTENTION TODAY AND LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU
AUTHORS OFFICE THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
CAN AFTERNOON CHAIR I'M STILL
DEBBIE TOTH I'M STILL WITH
CHOICE AN AGING -- I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR PUTTING THIS BILL
FORWARD AM I WANT TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL AND I WANNA BLOW IT UP
I WANT TO MAKE IT.
BIGGER -- FOLLOWING CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY BECAUSE OUR PROGRAMS AT
TREES AN AGING WHERE WE SERVE
ADULT A HEALTH CARE PROGRAMS
WERE LICENSED HEALTH CARE
FACILITY WE BRING FOLKS IN.
THEY RECEIVE HEALTH SERVICES
THAT THEY WOULD RECEIVE AT A
SKILLED NURSING FACILITY AND
THEN THEY GO HOME AND THEY SLEEP
IN THEIR OWN BEDS INSTEAD OF
BEING IN INSTITUTIONS.
SO GETTING TO AND FROM OUR
PROGRAMS MOST FOLKS TAKE
PARATRANSIT SERVICES THAT'S THAT
EIGHTY A REQUIRED SERVICE.
THAT THE TRANSIT PROVIDERS MUST
PROVIDE THERE IS A LACK OF
PERSON CENTERED DIGNIFIED.
SOME SORT OF LEVEL OF WHAT IS
OKAY AND THAT OKAY -- I WILL
TELL YOU A STORY OF A WOMAN WHO
ATTENDS OUR FARSI PROGRAM WE
HAVE MULTIPLE PROGRAMS IN ONE OF
OUR PROGRAMS IS A FARSI SPEAKING
PROGRAM.
YOU DON'T MIND KEEPING IT BRIEF.
SHE WAS ON THE BUS HER HOUSE IS
SEVEN POINT SIX MILES FROM OUR
CENTER.
IN TWO HOURS INTO HER TRIP SHE
ASKED THE DRIVER TO STOP SO SHE
COULD GO TO THE RESTROOM AND THE
DRIVER DID NOT STOP AND CHANNING
CONTENTS EPISODE ON THE BUS.
IT'S NOT JUST A WORLD PROBLEM.
IT'S A HUMAN DIGNITY PROBLEM AND
SO I SUPPORT THIS AND I ASK THAT
YOU.
BLOW IT UP AN EXPANDED LARGER
THANK YOU.
RESEARCHER GOOD AFTERNOON AGAIN
JOHN PORTER CALIFORNIA SCENE
LEGISLATURE I THINK THE
ARGUMENTS HAVE BEEN CLEARLY
ARTICULATED.
AND WE STRONGLY SUPPORT.
PASSAGE OF THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
MY NAME IS KATHERINE GARCIA
NUMBER SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIA.
OUR MEMBERS ARE OPPOSED TO
SPECIFIC LANGUAGE IN ASSEMBLY
BILL NINE SEVENTY THAT WOULD
UNDERMINE THE EFFECTIVENESS OF
THE GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION
FUND G. G. R. F..
R. MEMBERS ASK THE REMOVED NEAR
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES FROM THE
BILL.
AB NINE SEVENTY WOULD PROVIDE
CLEAN TRANSPORTATION ASSISTANCE
FOR SENIORS AND THOSE LIVING
WITH DISABILITIES WHICH WE AGREE
IS VERY IMPORTANT.
HOWEVER THE LEGISLATION
CURRENTLY STATE FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF AGING WOULD
RECEIVE G. G. R. F.
APPROPRIATIONS FOR ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES AND NEAR ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES.
THE DUDE EUROPE IS INTENDED TO
HELP CALIFORNIA TRANSITION TO A
SUSTAINABLE FUTURE.
THE APPROPRIATIONS SHOULD FIND
PROVEN PROGRAMS THAT REDUCE
EMISSIONS IN THE SHORT TERM AND
HELP CALIFORNIA ACHIEVE ITS
CLIMATE GOALS.
WHEN IT COMES TO CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES PROVIDE THE MOST
EFFECTIVE PUBLIC HEALTH BENEFIT
BY REDUCING HARMFUL GREENHOUSE
GAS AND CRITERIA MISSIONS?
THERE ARE ZERO MISSION SHUTTLES
THAT ARE AVAILABLE FOR PURCHASE
HEARING CALIFORNIA.
SO WE URGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER SALAS
TO PLEASE AMEND AB NINE SEVENTY
TO ENSURE THAT YOU DO YOUR AFTER
APPROPRIATIONS PROVIDE THE
MAXIMUM BENEFIT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER COMMENTS.
OF BRINGING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS.
WHAT WAS THE LARGE IS A SORRY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SALAS WHAT WAS
THE LOGIC OF INCLUDING THE NEAR
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES NOT JUST
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES AND YOUR
BILL?
WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS TRYING TO
EXPAND THIS TO AS MANY SENIORS
AS POSSIBLE AND SOME OF THESE
AREAS IT'S ALMOST IMPOSSIBLE TO
GET SOME OF THESE VEHICLES
ESPECIALLY WITH A FUNDING THAT'S
ATTACHED TO THEM.
SO WE'RE TRYING TO BE AS
ENVIRONMENTALLY FRIENDLY AS
POSSIBLE WITHOUT DISADVANTAGING
SENIORS GETTING TO THEIR
APPOINTMENTS AT THE END OF THE
DAY WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE GETTING FOLKS. TO AND FROM
THEIR APPOINTMENTS AND SO THAT'S
WHY WE HAD THAT LANGUAGE IN
THERE. TO ALLOW -- ZERO AND
YEARS ZERO BECAUSE WE DON'T WANT
TO EXCLUDE.
SENIORS ARE PARTS OF THE STATE
WHERE THIS IS A A REAL HARDSHIP --
FOR THE SENIORS TO THEN BE LEFT
OUT OF NOT GETTING TO THEIR
APPOINTMENTS YOU KNOW THE
MOTIVATION IS REALLY GETTING
PEOPLE TO AND FROM THEIR
APPOINTMENTS.
CLEARLY BUT IT ARE YOU SAYING
THAT THERE ARE YOUR YOU ADDED
THE NEAR ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES
BECAUSE OF SOME AREAS WERE
EASY'S.
DON'T HAVE SUFFICIENT RANGE WELL
SOMETIMES IT'S A RANGE BUT IT'S
ALSO THE LACK OF THE
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR CHARGING
THOSE UNITS [inaudible]
YES.
STRESS THANK YOU I DON'T HAVE MY
OWN MIKE -- NO NO I'M KIDDING
HE'S ALREADY PROVIDED THAT TO ME.
OF I DO WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS ONE WHEN I HAVE MY
SENIOR ADVOCACY WEEKS -- EVERY
YEAR. ONE OF THE TOP COMPLAINTS
FROM MY SENIORS IS LACK OF
TRANSPORTATION.
AND I I THINK THAT IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE BE AS CREATIVE
AS POSSIBLE A PRE APPRECIATE
THAT YOU ARE BEING CREATIVE IN
THIS.
I APPRECIATE -- ZERO CLUBS
COMMENTS BECAUSE IN THE END
THERE REALLY LOOKING TO THE BEST
THING FOR OUR FUTURE.
BECAUSE WHEN WHEN THE VEHICLES
ARE ARE POLLUTING OUR AIR IT'S
OUR SENIORS AND ARE VERY YOUNG
CHILDREN THE ONES WHO SUFFER THE
MOST -- AND WE WANT TO BE SURE
THAT WE DO THE VERY BEST THAT WE
CAN FOR BOTH BUT I'M VERY GLAD
THAT THAT YOU BROUGHT THIS
FORWARD.
TRANSPORTATION FOR OUR SENIORS
AND NOT JUST FOR MEDICAL
APPOINTMENTS IF THEY WANT TO GO
VISIT A FRIEND IF THE WHATEVER
IT IS THEY WANT TO DO WE NEED TO
BE ABLE. TO TO TO PROVIDE MORE
FOR THEM I KNOW IT COSTS MONEY
WE SPEND MONEY ON A LOT OF OTHER
THINGS AND I I AGAIN I
APPRECIATE THAT YOU BROUGHT THIS
IN HERE.
THANK YOU MISTER S..
ECHO THE COMMENTS -- THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD --
AND THAT'S THE NUMBER ONE
COMPLAINT THAT I HAVE AS WELL IN
MY DISTRICT THAT SENIORS DON'T
HAVE THE ABILITY. TO TO TO
ACCESS -- BECAUSE OF
TRANSPORTATION AND SO THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD AND I
UNDERSTAND -- YOU KNOW THE
REASONS THAT THAT YOU -- BROUGHT
THIS -- AND I APPRECIATE THAT
YOU ARE THINKING UPS OUTSIDE OF
THE BOX AND I KNOW THAT YOU'VE
BEEN CRITICIZED FOR NOT -- FOR
OTHER THINGS AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT YOU'RE THINKING
CREATIVELY TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR
SENIORS ARE TAKING CARE OF AND I
KNOW THAT THE SENIOR POPULATION
APPRECIATED AS WELL.
THANK YOU APPRECIATE THOSE CALLS
[inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
SEEING NO OTHER COMMENTS WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE AT
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
I MEAN LET'S HELP AS MANY
SENIORS AS WE CAN.
AND NOT LET THE JUST
RESPECTFULLY ASK WHATEVER THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER CELIS
EVEN GIVEN A PLACE LIKE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY WITH THE BENEFITS
AND THE RESOURCES THAT WE HAVE
AVAILABLE AND A PROGRAM THAT WE
HAVE THROUGH -- ACCESS -- WHICH
IS A MULTI MILLION DOLLAR
PROGRAM COMMITTED ONLY TO
PROVIDING THE SERVICE OF
TRANSPORTATION NON EMERGENCY
TRANSPORTATION.
WE STILL SEE WHAT THE NEEDS ARE --
HOW DESPERATE THE VARIOUS
COMMUNITIES ARE WHAT THE G.
GEOGRAPHIC OF OF OF ROLE IS THAT
PLEASE AND AND -- THE CHALLENGES
THAT WE HAVE BEEN PROVIDING
SERVICES TO EVERYONE.
WHO IS IN NEED SO -- THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD THIS
BILL IS DOUBLE REFERRED GOING TO
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE NEXT SO
I THINK THAT WOULD BE THE VERY
APPROPRIATE FORM FOR SIERRA CLUB --
TO CONTINUE ITS CONVERSATIONS
WITH THE AUTHOR THANK YOU SO
MUCH UP WITH THAT THERE'S A
MOTION BY MISS BROUGH BO AND A
SECOND BY MISTER LACKEY -- LET'S
OPEN THE ROLE.
AB.
NINE SEVENTY THE NET NAZARIAN I
AM VERY NICE VOEPEL.
HELLO HI WARNER HARD ROCK HI.
WARNER HER ROTH AYE KALRA
[inaudible]
SIGN.
KALRA I LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE REYES.
HI.
RES I RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE IF THE MEASURE PASSES.
THANK YOU MISTER CELIS
[inaudible]
OF THAT.
ITEM NUMBER TWO AT WAS -- THE
NUMBER SEVEN NINETY SEVEN BY
MISTER GRAYSON THAT HAS BEEN
PULLED SO WE WILL GO TO ITEM
NUMBER -- FOUR AB ELEVEN TWENTY
EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PETRIE-NORRIS.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND
MISTER CELIS ON YOUR WAY OUT
THANK YOU ALSO FOR YOUR PATIENCE
SORRY I WAS RUNNING A LITTLE
LATE.
PRESENTING MY OWN BILL IN
ANOTHER COMMITTEE.
THE PLACE I WANT.
UBIQUITOUS THIS IS A VIRTUE.
AND THAT WE CAN.
AFFORD.
HELLO CHAIR AND MEMBERS I'M HERE
TODAY TO ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
FOR EIGHTY ONE ONE TWO EIGHT AT
THE GOAL OF THIS BILL IS TO
EXPAND ACCESS TO PACE THE
PROGRAM AT ALL INCLUSIVE CARE
FOR THE ELDERLY.
I THE PROGRAM AMONG COLLUSIVE
CARE FOR THE ELDERLY ELDERLY
PACE.
IS A WELL RESPECTED EFFICIENT
PROGRAM THAT AIMS TO KEEP
SENIORS IN THEIR HOMES AND
COMMUNITIES NOT IN INSTITUTIONS.
PACERS ELIGIBLE PARTICIPANTS BY
PROVIDING ALL INCLUSIVE MEDICARE
AND MEDICAID ALL COVERED
BENEFITS THROUGH ONE STOP SHOP
HE'S CENTERS.
THEY PROVIDE PREVENTIVE PRIMARY
ACUTE AND LONG TERM CARE
SERVICES.
IS A PROVEN SUCCESS STORY ACROSS
THE STATE BENEFICIARIES HAVE
FEWER HOSPITALIZATIONS AND
NURSING HOME ADMISSIONS.
THE REPORT BETTER HEALTH AND
QUALITY OF LIFE AND HIGH RATES
OF SATISFACTION WITH OVERALL
CARE PIECES ALSO A MONEY SAVER
WHEN I COMPARE TO OTHER MODELS
OF CARE.
AND THE PROGRAM CURRENTLY SEIZE
THE STATE AN ESTIMATED TWENTY
THREE MILLION DOLLARS BUT THERE
IS A CRITICAL SHORTAGE OF PACE
PROVIDERS ACROSS THE STATE --
WE'RE EXPLORING A NUMBER OF
STRATEGIES TO TRY TO ADDRESS
THIS SHORTAGE AND INCREASED PACE
CAPACITY THE SOLUTION AND THIS
BILL IS REALLY.
STRAIGHTFORWARD ADMINISTRATIVE
ARE CURRENTLY PACE ORGANIZATIONS
BASED A COMPLEX AND LENGTHY
APPROVAL PROCESS TO START UP NEW
PROGRAMS AND EXPAND EXISTING
ONES.
THIS INCLUDES AN EXTENSIVE
APPROVAL PROCESS BY BOTH THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH.
THIS BIFURCATED PROCESS IS
INEFFICIENT AND TO PLAY COULD
HAVE AND CAN SIGNIFICANTLY
DELAYED THE ROLLOUT OF NEW AND
EXPANDING PACE PROGRAMS SO.
THIS BILL WILL ESSENTIALLY
CONSOLIDATE THE LICENSURE
FUNCTIONS OF PACE WITH IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES.
AND STREAMLINED APPROVALS FOR
NEW PAY START UPS -- AND
EXPANSIONS BY ALIGNING LICENSURE
TIME LINES WITH PROGRAM
IMPLEMENTATION.
I WE HAVE BEEN WORKING WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES ON THE SPELL AND WOULD
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT PLEASED TO INTRODUCE TO
WITNESSES HERE.
TO TESTIFY WITH US TODAY.
I MOVE THIS BILL.
WE CAN BE FIXED.
SO I'LL BE VERY SHORT AND I'LL
JUST ADD THAT IN ADDITION TO DH
CS IN THE DEPARTMENT OF
LICENSING.
ARE OR DPH WE ALSO HAVE THE SAME
OVERSIGHT BY CMS SO CMS AND DH
CS TO A GOOD JOB OF COORDINATING
THEIR COMING OUT AND LICENSING
US AND THEY ARE VERY STRICT
GUIDELINES ABOUT HOW FAST THEY
HAVE TO DO THAT.
BUT BEFORE THEY CAN DO THAT
THEY'VE GOT TO HAVE ALL THE
OTHER OF ISSUES LINED UP AND SO
THE DEPARTMENT OF LICENSING OR
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH IS
JUST SO BUSY RIGHT NOW.
WITH THE NUMBER OF HOSPITALS AND
CLINICS AND SO FORTH.
THAT WE FEEL LIKE CONSOLIDATING
THIS WHEN WE'VE DONE A SPREAD
SHEET YOU KNOW WHAT THEY'RE
LOOKING AT IS LIKE THE FIFTH
GROUP THAT CAME THROUGH AND LOOK
AT THE VERY SAME THINGS.
AND IT'LL BE MORE EFFICIENT WITH
A GROUP OF PEOPLE THAT
UNDERSTAND PACE.
AND WHO ARE ALREADY OUT THERE
DOING THE SAME THING.
AND I WOULD JUST ADD THAT RIGHT
NOW FOR MY OWN PROGRAM I AM THE
I'M LINDA TROWBRIDGE I FORGOT TO
SAY THAT AND I AM THE CAL PACE
CHAIR WHICH IS OUR ASSOCIATION
OF PAGE PROGRAMS IN THE STATE.
AS WELL AS THE C. E. O. CENTER
FOR ELDERS INDEPENDENCE IN IN
THE EAST BAY WHICH HAS BEEN
AROUND FOR THIRTY FIVE YEARS
STARTING OUT AS EIGHTY EIGHT
SEASON THEN ONE OF THE EARLY
REPLICATIONS OF PACE WHICH
UNLOCKED FOUNDED FORTY FIVE
YEARS AGO.
SO -- OF I HAD ONE OF MY SITES
DELAYED BY ALMOST THREE YEARS IN
TAKING MORE THAN A YEAR TO GET
THROUGH DEPARTMENT OF AGING AND
THEN TODAY PH AND THEN ON OUT.
AND THE SECOND ONE DELAYED BY
SIX MONTHS AND THESE PROGRAMS
ARE VERY -- BUILDING INTENSITY
OF IT TAKES.
SOMEWHERE BETWEEN EIGHT AND
TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS TO BUILD
PAY CENTER.
NOT TO MENTION THAT ONCE
LICENSING COMES OUT YOU'VE
ALREADY HAD TO HAVE YOUR STAFF
FIRED AND STANDING.
THERE WITHOUT ANY ABILITY TO
SERVE ANYBODY SO IT'S A HUGE
CHALLENGE TO REPLICATE -- AND
THE ONLY THE THING I'D AS IT
WERE PART OF A AN INITIATIVE
ORACLE LAB OR DAVE WITH ALL THE
PAGE PROGRAMS IN CALIFORNIA
OREGON AND WASHINGTON.
AND WORKING TO GROW
EXPONENTIALLY [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON ERIN LEVI
REPRESENTING ON LIKE SENIOR
HEALTH SERVICES.
JUST TO BE BRIEF HOMES ON LUCK
WAS -- FOUNDED IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY ONE AND WAS THE ORIGINAL
PACE PROGRAM FOR THE NATION --
WE'VE DEFINITELY SEEN THE GROWTH
AND EXPANSION OF PACE --
NATIONWIDE -- WHICH HAS BEEN
FANTASTIC AND LATELY IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA -- AFTER AS
THE PEACE VOTERS EIGHT PIPE PACE
MARGIN ASIAN ACT THEY SAY THAT
MATTERS AND MODERNIZATION ACT.
THE TWENTY SIXTEEN THE CAP --
REQUIRING THE NUMBER OF AB HE
SERVICES ARE PAYS PROGRAMS TO BE
LIMITED WAS LIFTED AND AS A
RESULT WE SAW THE PACE EXPANSION --
ROW QUITE RAPIDLY.
OF WE ARE VERY FORTUNATE THE
DEPARTMENT HEALTH CARE SERVICES
TO SEE THE VALUE OF PEACE AND IN
THE GOVERNOR'S JAN TEN BUDGET
HAS ACTUALLY PROPOSEDRESOURCES.
TO SUPPORT THESE THE EXPANSION
OF THESE APPLICATIONS FOR MANY
MANY YEARS WE ONLY SAW FIVE PACE
PROGRAMS OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ARE NOW AT TWELVE
WITH A IN THE HOPPER WAITING THE
APPLICATION PROCESS -- WE'RE
VERY MUCH THINK THAT THIS BILL
WILL NOT ONLY ELIMINATE THE
DUPLICATION.
IN THE APPLICATION PROCESS WHICH
HAS BEEN VERY CUMBERSOME OVER
THE YEARS AND COSTLY TO THE PACE
PROGRAMS AND FRANKLY THE STATE
AS WELL -- BUT WE THINK IT WILL --
GET THESE PACED PROGRAMS DODD TO
SENIORS FOR ALL SENIORS FASTER
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU -- ANY OTHER.
INDIVIDUALS IN SUPPORT
ORGANIZATIONS AND SUPPORT IF YOU
CAN JUST STATE YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION -- JET HAMPTON
LEADING IT'S CALIFORNIA AND
STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
PETER CALLOUS NON BEHALF OF ST
PAUL'S HOMES AND SERVICES FOR
THE AGING IN SAN DIEGO IN
SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MICHAEL MCLAUGHLIN VOLUNTEER
WITH A A RP AND WE SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHRISTIE WITH ON
BEHALF OF STOCKTON PACE AND
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON OFFERED ONLY DINO
HERE ON BEHALF OF ULTIMATE
HEALTH SERVICES IN STRONG
SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
PLEASE A COMMON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LONG TERM CARE
OMBUDSMAN ASSOCIATION.
WITH APOLOGIES FOR NOT GETTING
OUR LETTER AND SUPPORT IN TIME
WE ARE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
THEY'RE BROUGHT DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THE ON ERIN ON BEHALF OF THE
CENTER FOR ELDERS INDEPENDENCE
IN THE EAST BAY AND ALSO THE
BRANDON CENTER THE JEWISH HOME
LOS ANGELES IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR JUMP WHERE
CALIFORNIA C. LEGISLATURE
QUICKLY WE SUPPORT -- ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE ANY COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS.
I FROM THE COMMITTEE
[inaudible]
NO.
THE FLOOR IS YOURS RIGHT FOR
CLOSING COMMENTS THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
IS A GREAT PROGRAM AND WHATEVER
WE CAN DO TO OFFER THE SUPPORT
NECESSARY -- TO NOT ONLY ADVANCE
THE PROGRAM BUT ALSO AS HELP
STREAMLINE AS WE'RE TRYING TO
ATTEMPTING TO STREAMLINE
EVERYTHING ELSE IN THE ARENA OF
AGING RIGHT NOW.
IS -- WILL SERVE SO WITH THAT
YOU SUPPORT AT AYE
RECOMMENDATION -- LET'S OPEN THE
ROLE -- AND I BELIEVE THE MOTION
WAS MADE MADE BY THIS PRINTER
**** BATH AND SECONDED BY ROUTE
MISS RUBIO.
AB ELEVEN TWENTY EIGHT NAZARIAN.
I'M SORRY WAS IT MISTER MISTER
KALRA.
ALL RIGHT LET'S CONTINUE HI.
NAZARIAN AYE VOEPEL.
VOEPEL I WONDER HARD ROCK I
WONDER HOW ROTH AYE KALRA.
KALRA I LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE REYES.
REYES I LIKE RUBIO.
RUBIO BY MEASURE PASSES.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE
AGAIN AND WE'RE ADJOURNED -- WE
HAVE TO ADD ON MISTER KALRA
BELIEVE YOU'RE FINE -- AND LET'S
GO QUICKLY [inaudible]
YEAH.
LET'S START OUT WITH AB -- FOR
EIGHTY MISTER CELIS.
ROLE.
AB FOR EIGHTY REYES.
REYES AYE THANK YOU [inaudible]
THE SERVICE.
HI.
THERE'S A ONE MORE.
DID YOU GET THE CELLS A SECOND
BILL.
PERFECT.
THANK YOU